um I didn't even start really this
journey that I'm on right now until I
was older than you yeah no I get it and
and so for anybody who's listening or
watching television feel like it's too
late like I'm talking [ __ ]
you know I had a whole past life that
led me to a point that created a health
crisis and an existential crisis about
what I was doing and some confusing
years about trying to figure out like
how I wanted to move forward in the
world you know as I said in crushing it
like your work has been influential
thank you
and not just motivating me but providing
me with tools to really assess that for
myself and rich on that no but I'm sorry
yeah let me just finish this thought
which is you know it's been you know my
life is an embarrassment of riches right
now
but it's really a function of hard work
and patience and diligence and and being
really dedicated to the process and
being detached from the results which is
somebody somebody that's exact yeah and
dude it's the [ __ ] process like you
will look back when you become the
biggest when you put that [ __ ] star
in Hollywood I promise you when you're
sitting with you know the grandchildren
or people that look up to you you're
gonna romance about this time way more
than the [ __ ] hits yeah process yeah
what do you what do you think back on
you know like I've done these crazy
transgresses yeah but I don't think
about crossing the finish line I think
about that day I didn't want to get out
of bed like that's what gives it meaning
for me yeah and in terms of your
question of like what you know what is
the question I want to ask the audience
everything that I've been able to
accomplish is a function a direct result
of investing in trying to more deeply
connect with myself so my question the
audience really is like who are you you
know who the [ __ ] are you and if you
can't answer that question honestly for
yourself you can pick a goal and you can
be motivated by Gary and take advantage
of the tools that he puts out in the
world but you might be climbing a ladder
that's leaning up against the wrong wall
so you really need to take the time to
step back and and really get to know who
you are like what is your design and
what is it that gets you out of bed and
excited and if you can be super honest
about that and like crack the you know
veneer of denial and all these things
that hold you back that is the path
forward but if you want to just leapfrog
over that because you think that's an
inconvenience
you can go yeah you can chase stuff your
whole life but you're never gonna be a
fully-integrated authentic person and
you're never going to achieve you're
never gonna be able to share what it is
that is most valuable not to just to
yourself but but to whoever happens to
be paying attention to whatever they're
doing